have you ever wondered how your skincare  products get made this is the ego  factory where they make brands like  sunsets qv aquium and as clear first the  ingredients get weighed and pumped out  according to their secret formula which  has been tested with lots of fancy and  less fancy equipment to make sure they  feel right and don't separate or go  mouldy before you finish them up the  ingredients get mixed in giant fats then  everyone's favorite part the product  gets put into bottles and cartons and  then shipped to your local store i could  watch this all day i have a whole bunch  more footage of this so let me know if  you want me to turn that into a whole  separate video